I think of Moana as being in this unique
and beautiful role of a bridge between
identity-based alumni groups and
identity-based student groups and she
provides programming where those two
separate groups of people get to come
together and build community
I create this environment so they can
come in and feel excited to talk to each
other
it's their event when they show up it
looks fantastic
for example the Bandit Capstone project
which was the 50-year celebration of the
black student union and Moana put
together this insane conference
president reiff spoke Larry Bako spoke
Shirley Jackson spoke there were all
these really interesting professors who
came together students were there alumni
were there and it was just such a
beautiful event full of love and energy
and it was a safe place and it was just
so special and I think at the end of it
she knew that she had done a good job
but I don't think she knew the impact
that she had and just coming in as a new
staff member to the MIT Community I saw
that event it was like wow this is a
great place to work where we honor
people's experiences whether they were
terrible 50 years ago when they were
students and were trying to heal it or
whether they're a student now and
they're an activist and they're trying
to make it better for future students
like Moana gave space for all of that
and it had such a great impact and I
just would want her to be aware of that
so many of our staff and colleagues that
are doing the hard work of creating
environments for our alumni to
to feel sense of belonging
to a place making MIT more welcoming and
more inclusive
while I fully appreciate the honor of
receiving this award I long for the day
when we don't give Awards to people for
doing the work that they need to do
you know what I mean